this is just so we have a lot of backlog
questions here we want to get people on
the air here are you ready chuck here we
go question answer ready go from twitter
this is noah stevens at noah stevens if
we measure deadliness as the percentage
of global population killed what is the
most deadly deadly plague in history
the 1918 influenza oh nice awesome 1918.
whoa great year unless
is that worse than the plague in the
14th century in terms of total numbers
yes in terms of percentage population
plague was the worst
percentage
how many people died in 1918 uh it
depends on somewhere between 75 and 100
million
whoa okay that's twice the number of
deaths in the second world war go don't
get the sniffles in 1918 yeah uh this is
from um mahasan abdullah in the case of
viruses and vaccines if a disease gets
eradicated okay will future generations
still have to get vaccinated for those
diseases no not nice good okay she's
she's getting the hang of this she's
good all right so once it's gone it's
all gone aka smallpox we don't vaccinate
anymore all right here you go from
amanda
this is okay what do you think is the
most interesting historical plague or
epidemic viral or otherwise and why is
it so fascinating
plague it completely reshaped europe
forever
the politics the the culture the the
status of the church the okay which play
had many outbreaks which one is special
what's the big one gotcha
black plague
black death okay white's gotta be a
black dick
okay say that for another show
yeah all of a sudden that's a bad thing
here we go this is check
this is what zach sells
if a global epidemic broke out in the
third world how long would we expect it
to take to reach across the planet
also are we more susceptible to a
pandemic now because of air and sea
travel are less vulnerable due to
improvements in the medical uh um
community no way to answer the first one
because it depends on the dynamics of
the spread of the particular microbe and
the second one of course we're more
vulnerable because we're moving around
more gotcha okay so mobility matters
greatly and have we actually
counteracted that vulnerability through
medical technology
well the better you'll counter it with
surveillance gotcha okay so not
technology but keep an eye on it gotcha
so we need an nsa for viruses good
gotcha next what is the simplest way
this is from courtney lake what is the
simplest way you have found to explain
herd immunity have you ever encountered
an anti-vaccination believer to the
science of vaccines in your community
not not just people who don't believe in
vaccines
is there any science for that there well
there's plenty of science for why herd
immunity helps and works and what
happens when it's not working and we
have a measles outbreak out of control
in wales right now okay because the
anti-vaccine people won over so much of
public opinion that people stopped
getting vaccinated
wow so just look to wales courtney
there's your answer all right
could pathogens be from jared connor
could pathogens be spread in the
atmosphere a recent study done by
georgia tech researchers found that e
coli amongst a great deal of bacteria
that formed a sort of bacterial sphere
in the upper atmosphere yes we now have
proof that pathogens particularly
sporulating ones can spread in clouds
and rain down in locations far away oh
man that is one time you do not want to
make it rain ooh do you do you stay
inside when that happens well you don't
drink rainbow don't know it's coming and
you don't know it's you don't know for
nothing next okay here's a good one from
al geraldi we're still in the lightning
round we're still right man she's
killing it better than i ever
okay what is the minimum size sorry from
algeria what is the minimum size of a
population that can support a viral
infection
what does support what do we have so in
other words uh for for the virus itself
to to be able to continue on its life
what's the minimum number of people you
need in a community so it can spread and
continue to be a virulent in theory
one if that if it's a slow growing
microbe and a slow replicating one for
the duration of your life you can be the
host for it gotcha so in theory it could
just be a i could be a virus of one
like the army you got it
okay next this is from this might be the
last one okay quick this is from richard
fox
has the link between a chicken virus and
obesity been proven didn't even know we
were asking that question in science but
first time i ever heard there was a link
between a chicken virus and obesity
i think
by chicken virus he means like a whole
chicken and eating one in a city
fried fried chicken
a certain fried chicken shop for way too
long exactly fried chicken let's see we
got one more in here one more last one
here we go quick uh do the viruses used
to transfer gene traits into gmo course
uh survive in crops
no
boom what better [__]
oh my damn she rocked it holy you
crushed that lightning round you crushed
it
that's all you got well i do have she's
calling you out no
let's see if you can get this one in if
the human body's temperature rises when
it gets a virus couldn't that be an
explanation for what the planet is going
through right now the planet is pretty
much created by uh created so we
couldn't have similarities
because temperature rises because of
your immune response
a fever is part of your immune response
against a microbe not a good analogy to
the planet dude except in the matrix
when the the
smith said
you were fightless virus on the earth
glory garrett thank you for being on
star talk radio and illuminating our
inquisitive
uh uh listeners on infectious disease
that was awesome and viruses